hey everyone so let's uh so today's
discussion is about tidy pandas so tidy
pandas is a
python Library so this is a combination
of two nice things one is pandas which
is the de facto data frame
implementation in Python and uh title
SMB player which is another amazing
Library that's written in our so uh
using both of these things
for years so there were a few
realizations in terms of how we could
bring the niceness or a beauty of deep
liar
in Python and make and have pandas have
a nice layer on top of it
so tidy pointers was an effort which uh
led to a library and this package
provides a minimal and a pythonic
interface and like a RH interface for
the most common data manipulation tasks
and it's fundamentally inspired by tidy
version deeply
so we go through a few examples before
that let's see what it primarily offers
so ID pandas has a tidy frame class
which is essentially a wrapper over the
pandas data frame right so all the heavy
uh call the heavy lifting work is done
by pandas so there's this is a thin
layer on top of my list
so tidy frame provides data Prime uh the
beauty here is that it creates a very
simplified index structure essentially
no index at all so you'll never have to
worry about resetting your indexes
uh it offers consistent works like
select very interesting so if you
already know replier you're already
familiar with this
and it offers a very unified interface
whether you're summarizing or whether
you're assigning columns
across groups or without groups
so with groups your syntax doesn't
really change so we'll see that in a
minute
um so we also do a node.data no copy
conversion of data when you're actually
converting between tidy frame and Panda
State Defense
uh also we provide accessor
so what accessor does is it directly
lets you use the Tidy Frameworks or tidy
frame methods on top of a contact
we'll see that in action
so
the fundamental question always comes
that we have so many libraries why do we
want to have another one which is
justice so uh
again this this is finally written in
order to use it so I'm being the primary
user of this Library uh
these are the reasons I have why you
would want to use this effect
um
so you you would like to use study
Founders if you frequently write data
manipulation code in pandas and if you
prefer to stay in the pandas ecosystem
right at the same time you just want to
remember a small set of methods not 500
odd methods which pandas offers you
right and you do not want to write a lot
of reset indexes rename accesses and
every time print the data frame and see
what it's really doing in the background
I I also it lets you write a free
flowing expressive style in deployer
right so let's get into action let's see
how this goes
okay so here we go so tidy painters
often creates compact code
so let's see the comparison between a
simple operation
so operation here is to filter a column
for all the values which is greater than
its mean value
Group by column two
so the first statement here pretty much
reads by itself
now when we do this in pandas we would
actually take three steps right we have
a group I a column two and then you got
to apply L Lambda function over it right
and then you go to reset the index to
set it back
so this is an example where we avoid
resetting the index at the same time
create a very clean compact critical
curve
let's move on
so because of the structure this is a
very open-ended point though tight
defined as keeps the focus on analysis
and not on the data structure
so here is another relatively
complicated flow so let's see what's
happening in tidy binders so the first
line basically creates a new column but
n carriers it's a number of distinct
carriers grouped by destination
so the second filter uh second line is a
filter where it fictional carriers which
are having number greater than one
and the third one third line summarizes
essentially creates an underscore
destination column
which creates distinct destinations
Group by carrier right and then it are
in just with a number of destinations in
descending order
now if we were writing this in pandas in
the pipe style you would have to
basically do a lot of operations so your
groupies stay outside the context and
this is where we feel uh tidy pandas
creates a lot of a compact code at the
same time very explainable at each line
so you'll have to group by apply look at
the third line we'll have to reset the
index so usually what happens to most
users is that you've got to print that
and see what really happens so it takes
your flow away from your analysis right
and you see another group by an
aggregation probably on line seven and
eight
that that lets you and you got to again
rename what you have done in the
aggregation so when you do this and you
keep constantly printing your data and
takes a lot of time and takes you away
from your thought process so we believe
uh tidy pandas really should help us in
that regard
and tidy pointers uh really works
towards a lot of consistency
so if you see the first three statements
and try to pointers so all three of them
return your tidy data frame
depending on the the method that's
called
okay so these things could be really
painful when you're doing the analysis
so this really matters
so tidy pandas as I said avoids index
altogether so thereby avoids any
complicated multi-index
so this is a widening operation or a
date of time
as you can see we picked the names from
our two columns sex and species and the
values from here and we're simply
widening it and when you see this
happening right and then we take a
aggregation over mean so when we see
this it's a tidy point of state of frame
create a simple data frame you can see
the index is 0 1 and 2 right they're
nothing but error numbers
whereas the pivot table operation in
Paradise creates a similar object but
creates a very complicated
multi-intention now I'm wrangling this
could be a real headache right this is
one of the points where we feel that a
lot of data analysis can and should be
done without using indexes and mighty
indexes should something we should avoid
at all costs
right so here is an example where 3D
printers offers an accessor for the
pandas data frames so this is for those
guys who say I am working with my pandas
data frames tell me if there's something
that I could use Quick right so here's
the way so import tidy accessor sdp so
once you've done that that on your
pandas data frames you could directly
call
pandas Thai dependence methods
so if you recall this example from a
first slide so I'm actually calling this
filter right where give me every row
where Bill and mm has value greater than
its mean broken by species
so when you see this the output is a
part of state of line so input is a part
of the state of frame you use a tidy
Pand as well and the negative output
which is a point of state of frame so
you could go back to your pandas
workflow at any point
and mind everything is done here without
making a copy at any point of time we
directly refer to the underlying object
without making any change to it
right so uh so we bought all the finding
fine points so I'll quickly go back to
uh our first slide which basically spoke
about what are the advantages I'll go
back to this again uh because this kind
of tells us what we're trying to do
right we have a simplified index we have
consistent verbs we have a unified
interface for aggregation assigning your
columns across groups right we don't
make a copy between uh tidy frame and
pandas and if you prefer not to we offer
an accessor so all of these things
should make the data analysis very
elegant right so with this we saw a few
working samples where we really saw
examples where things become very
compact right and all the underlying
code is written in Panda so it is as
fast as pandas can get type and uh tidy
pandas is available on poipi there's a
GitHub repo this website uh will be very
happy to take your suggestions issues
and the first release happened on April
2022 this year and we've been having
nine releases since then and uh a very
active project that's been maintained
and we want to maintain this very good
long time
yeah
thank you that's it from my side